>> IT'S BEEN A DIFFICULT YEAR
FOR BRITAIN'S ROYAL FAMILY,
FROM A VERY PUBLIC RIFT TO THE
LOSS OF THEIR BELOVED PATRIOTIC,
WHO WOULD'VE TURNED 100 YEARS
OLD ON THURSDAY.
MAX FOSTER SAT DOWN WITH THE
PEARL OF WESSEX TO TALK ABOUT
THE LEGACY, AND HOW THE
MONARCHY IS TALKING WITH THE
LATEST CHALLENGES.
>> THEY LIVE HERE IN WINDSOR
LEAR BY THE QUEEN.
THEY ARE PARTICULARLY CLOSE.
EVENTUALLY EDWARD WILL INHERIT
THE TITLE OF THE DUKE OF
EDINBURGH.
I ASKED HIM ABOUT HIS FATHER'S
LEGACY.
>>-YEAR-OLD HIGHNESS, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR SPEAKING TO US,
IT IS A VERY POIGNANT TIME OF
COURSE.
I KNOW YOU WANT TO FOCUS ON
CELEBRATING YOUR FATHER'S LIFE
AT THIS POINT.
INDEED.
>> NOT JUST A BROAD LIFE, BUT A
LIFE THAT WAS INVOLVED IN SO
MANY DIFFERENT INTERESTS, AND
HE TRAVELED SO MUCH AND HE SAW
SO MUCH.
NOT ONLY THAT BUT HE WAS THE
SORT OF PERSON THAT ONCE MET,
NEVER FORGOTTEN.
>> IT WOULD'VE BEEN YOUR
FATHER'S 100TH BIRTHDAY, HOW DO
YOU THINK HE LOOKS BACK ON HIS
PUBLIC WORK?
>> HE WAS ALWAYS, ALWAYS
INCREDIBLY --
HE JUST GAVE THEM THE NUDGE OF
ENCOURAGEMENT AND OFF HE WENT.
TRAGICALLY, IT WASN'T UNTIL HE
PASSED AWAY THAT EVERYBODY WENT,
WOW, THAT IS WHAT HE DID.
OF COURSE IT IS TOO LATE.
BUT THEN, I SUSPECT THAT IF HE
HAD MADE IT TO HIS 100TH
BIRTHDAY, A LOT OF THAT
WOULD'VE COME OUT.
IT WOULD'VE BEEN LOVELY FOR HIM
TO HAVE HEARD IT HIMSELF.
BUT THEN AGAIN, BECAUSE HE WAS
JUST SO SELF FACING, HE JUST
WOULDN'T WANT THE FUSS AND I
DON'T THINK HE WANTED TO REACH
THAT.
HE JUST THOUGHT IT WOULD BE TOO
MUCH FUSS.
THAT WAS JUST NOT HIM AT ALL.
>> MANY PEOPLE MAY THINK OF IT
AS AN OUTWARD BOUND SCHEME.
BUT IT IS MORE THAN THAT, IT IS
ALMOST A MOTIVATIONAL SELF
CONFIDENT EXERCISE.
>> IT IS A FRAMEWORK.
THAT IS A FRAMEWORK OF
ACTIVITIES.
IT IS TO ENCOURAGE YOUNG PEOPLE,
AND ADULTS TO GET INVOLVED IN
THESE ACTIVITIES.
AND OF COURSE, IT IS EMPOWERED
BOTH ADULTS AND YOUNG PEOPLE TO
TAKE CONTROL OF THEIR
DESTINIES.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHERE IN THE
WORLD, IN FACT THAT YOUNG
PERSON OR ADULT IS, IT IS THE
SAME.
THAT IS THE REASON WHY I THINK
IT SPREAD TO 130 COUNTRIES.
IT IS DOING PARTICULARLY WELL
IN THE STATES, IT WAS A BIT OF
A LATE START, BUT IT IS
BRILLIANT.
AND WHAT IS VERY EXCITING ABOUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE STATE,
NEARLY 50% OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE
INVOLVED OR FROM WHAT WE WOULD
CALL AT RISK OR MARGINALIZED
YOUNG PEOPLE, AND DISADVANTAGED
YOUNG PEOPLE, AND THAT IS
BRILLIANT BECAUSE THOSE ARE THE
PEOPLE THAT CAN VERY MUCH
BENEFIT FROM THIS.
>> WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT HIS
OTHER ROLES, A BIGGER ROLE,
ARGUABLY, HIS ROLE AS --
PROBABLY THE BIGGEST INFLUENCE
ON ARGUABLY ONE OF THE BIGGEST
RAINS OF BRITISH HISTORY, AWAY
FROM THE QUEEN.
CAN I ASK HOW SHE IS COPING
WITHOUT HIM?
>> THANK YOU FOR ASKING.
I THINK ACTUALLY, WE'RE DOING
REMARKABLY WELL.
IT WAS A FANTASTIC PARTNERSHIP.
LIFE HAS GOTTEN CONSIDERABLY
BUSIER.
THINGS ARE BEGINNING TO OPENING
UP.
THERE ARE MORE ACTIVITIES.
THAT SORT OF FILLS ANY
PARTICULAR VOID, I THINK
THEY'RE GOING TO BE OTHER TIMES,
WHERE IT WILL BECOME MORE
POIGNANT AND A BIT HARDER.
AT THE MOMENT, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH INDEED FOR ASKING, BUT I
THINK EVERYONE IS IN GOOD
SHAPE.
>> I DON'T UPRIGHT TOO MUCH,
BUT THIS IS A PRIVATE MATTER
BUT IT'S ALSO VERY PUBLIC, BUT
THAT MUST OF BEEN A FAMILY RIFT,
THAT MUST HAVE BEEN VERY
DIFFICULT FOR HER.
HOW IS SHE COPING WITH THAT,
CAN I ASK?
>> IT ALL DEPENDS --
ARE YOU EUPHEMISTICALLY WERE
FRYING TO HARRY AND MEGHAN?
>> YES.
[LAUGHS]
YES, THE DIVIDE BETWEEN THE
SUSSEXES AND THE REST OF THE
FAMILY CURRENTLY.
>> YEAH.
IT IS VERY SAD.
WE HAVE ALL BEEN THERE BEFORE.
WE'VE ALL HAD EXCESSIVE
INTRUSIONS AND ATTENTION IN OUR
LIVES.
WE'VE ALL DEALT WITH IT IN
DIFFERENT WAYS.
LISTEN, WE WISH THEM THE VERY
BEST OF LUCK.
IT IS A VERY HARD DECISION.
FANTASTIC NEWS ABOUT THE BABY.
I HOPE THEY WILL BE VERY HAPPY.
FAMILY AS A FAMILY.
>> THEY ARE.
THEY DO HAPPEN IN ALL FAMILIES,
IT'S JUST THE VERY PUBLIC
NATURE OF THIS, I WONDER HOW
THAT MUST OF BEEN FOR HER?
>> IT IS DIFFICULT FOR
EVERYONE.
IT IS DIFFICULT FOR EVERYONE.
BUT AS I SAID, THAT IS
FAMILIES.
>> WE TALKED ABOUT HOW SHE JUST
CARRIES ON IN A VERY REMARKABLE
WAY, A VERY INSPIRING WAY, THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
CURRENTLY IN THE UNITED KINGDOM,
THE QUEEN HAS MET SO MANY
PRESIDENTS, I WONDER WHAT IT
MUST BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THOSE HEADS OF STATES TO SPEAK
TO SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN THERE,
DONE THAT, HAD THAT EXPERIENCE
AS WELL?
>> WHEN YOU MEET SOMEBODY WHO
HAS HAD THAT LEVEL OF PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE AND KNOWLEDGE, --
SOME PEOPLE, AND I THINK MOST
PEOPLE WISH THEY HAD A BIT
LONGER.
THAT'S USUALLY THE RESPONSE.
GOD, I WANTED TO HAVE A LITTLE
BIT LONGER, BECAUSE THAT WAS
FASCINATING.
>> THEY ALWAYS STAY PRIVATE
THESE CONVERSATIONS.
IT IS ALMOST LIKE A HIGH LEVEL
OF COUNSELING, IN MANY WAYS.
PRIME MINISTERS HAVE SPOKEN
ABOUT THAT.
>> IT IS VERY IMPORTANT.
THE FACT THAT THEY ALL SAY IT
PRIVATELY IS SOMETHING THAT IS
VERY STRANGE IN THIS WORLD.
U.S. PEER TO APPEAR
INSTANTANEOUSLY, THE FACT THAT
NOTHING LIKE THAT HAPPENS
DOESN'T MEAN THAT PEOPLE REALLY
DO RESPECT THE FACT THAT THIS
IS A GENUINELY PRIVATE, OFF THE
RECORD, CONVERSATION.
THEY REALLY CAN TALK ABOUT
THINGS.
GET TO THE HEART OF THINGS IN A
VERY GENUINE FASHION.
THEY KNOW IT IS NOT GOING TO
COME OUT.
>> HAS SHE EVER SLEPT --
>> NOTHING.
EVEN IF I DID, I FORGOT ABOUT
IT THE VERY NEXT DAY.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
SPEAKING WITH ME.
>> THANK YOU FOR YOUR INTEREST.
>> JOHN WE WILL BE BACK HERE IN
WINDSOR IN SUNDAY WHEN
PRESIDENT BIDE